number one idiot yeah right yeah that
was the hierarchy of videos yeah he's
the dumbest person that you could be in
the NBA it's yeah it's a young dumb and
immature no no I'm tired of this young
dumb 19 year old ukrainians out there
that are getting caught up in Russia
right but they're telling their guns
though
[Music]
places you could do it legally and be
rewarded and play ball too probably
there was a dude it was a I think
his brick boy or something like that he
was rolling 60 and he was like yo if you
want to be about that life come come be
with us for a weekend yeah you want to
touch you Logan come spend a weekend
yeah yeah and he was like yeah it's like
a study abroad is that open